INT: We are March
28, 1995, on Tuesday.
Peter Fischl, a survivor,
and the interviewer
is Trish Deux Degennaro.
We are in the city of Los
Angeles, California in the USA,
and we are using
English language.
[PAUSES FOR 5 SECONDS]
OK.
My name is Trish Deux Degennaro.
We are at 3/28/95.
I'm interviewing Peter Fischl.
And we're in Burbank,
California, USA.
Peter, can you tell us
your name and spell it?
And also where you were
born, when you were born,
and if you had any nickname.
PF: My name is Peter
Leopold Fischl.
And it's spelled P-E-T-E-R
L-E-O-P-O-L-D F-I-S-C-H-L.
And actually, that's in English.
In-- and-- and the nickname--
my nickname in-- in-- in America
would be Pete,
P-E-T-E. In Hungary,
my name would be Fischl
Peter, Fischl Leopold Peter.
And my-- my nickname in-- in
Hungary would be not Pete,
but-- I don't know what
my nickname would be.
INT: It's OK if you
don't have any nickname.
If they didn't call you--
PF: I did, but I forget now.
INT: It's OK.
Your date of birth?
PF: I was born in July 19,
1930, in Budapest, Hungary.
And what was the next question?
So--
INT: So, tell us, Peter, what
was life like before the war?
What was your family life?
PF: Generally
speaking it was great.
It was great.
My father was a very, very
successful businessmen,
and we lived a very, very
high middle-class life,
you would say in America.
And our [PAUSES FOR 4 SECONDS]
chauffeur
would take us to school
and pick us up and take us
to the horses for horse
riding and things like that.
And every year, we
would take vacations
in surrounding countries, visit.
INT: What's the
name of your father?
PF: Tibor, which
spells T-I-B-O-R.
Tibor is the-- is the
name of my father,
was the name of my father.
INT: And your mother?
PF: Was Edith, E-D-I-T-H.
INT: And what was she doing?
What was her, her occupation.
PF: My mother was a housewife.
And she was a daughter
of a, a doctor.
My grandfather was a doctor, a
professor here in a hospital.
He was an ear, nose,
throat specialist.
And so when my mother
married my father,
that she became a housewife.
And then we were born shortly,
and she took care of us.
INT: 'Us,' meaning you and--
PF: My sister.
I have a sister.
INT: What's her name and--
PF: Marika, Maria is her
name, my sister's name.
INT: So in the--
during the weekends,
what were you doing
with your family?
What was your family life like?
Were you going to
a, to a synagogue?
Or were you religious?
PF: As far as religion
is concerned, no,
we were not religious.
My grandmother was religious.
So many times my father
would take us over
to my grandmother's
place, and my sister and I
would stay there on the
weekend or something.
Then we would go
through all the rituals,
and all the religious rituals.
But other than
that, in our home,
we weren't religious at all.
We, we were not.
We did not go to synagogues
on a weekly basis.
Once in a great while we would,
but not on a regular basis,
we would not.
INT: So what was your hobby?
I mean, what were
you doing as a child?
PF: As a child, one time
I watched my father--
we had a piano at home.
And my father liked
to play the piano.
And at eight, seven, I was,
I was watching my father play
that old 'Sonny Boy' tune that's
from a very old, I think 1930,
American-- the first sound
movie, I think, in America.
Al Jolson, Al Jolson
was singing that tune.
[SINGING]
And I was listening to that,
and I said to my father,
I said, jeez, I
like this very much.
Can I learn that?
And he said, certainly.
So I sat next to
him, and that's how
I started playing the piano.
And I copied him and
played that tune.
And then many times
when I was alone,
I would play for hours, the same
tune over and over and over.
And it didn't bother me.
It probably bothered
the neighbors,
but it didn't bother me.
And then I started
learning other songs.
And interestingly enough, if
I liked a tune or something,
I was able, by trial and error,
to play another tune by myself.
And so piano was one.
And, and another thing was
at my grandmother's place,
she had a chess board.
And she taught, she taught me
how to set up chess figures.
And so at a very early age,
I started playing chess.
INT: How old?
Do you remember?
PF: Oh, about seven.
And I, and I learned
how to move correctly.
And I played with people.
And it enter--
entertained me a lot.
So that's how I
think in my life I
learned enjoying challenges a
lot from very early childhood.
Playing complicated things,
doing complicated things,
but enjoying it a lot.
I had [PAUSES FOR 4 SECONDS]
a gentlemen
who was about 12 years
older-- my grandmother hired
him to be my home teacher and
to, to, to teach me things.
And, and, and, and his first
this was, which at age seven
or so, he taught me
a poem in Hungarian.
[HUNGARIAN]
And that was about 50
years, 58 years ago.
And I still remember that.
That gentlemen now in Canada.
He's a literature professor
and teaches in college.
And I just wrote to him, isn't
it interesting that I have
learned my first poem from you.
INT: Can you tell me
what, what it means?
PF: Certainly.
It says, the [NON-ENGLISH]
is the person who's watching
the animals, and he's
sitting on a donkey.
And he says, [HUNGARIAN].
And his legs are
touching the ground.
And that's what it means.
And it's about
this [NON-ENGLISH],
this keeper who
watches-- a cowboy.
[PAUSES FOR 3 SECONDS]
That what this poem about.
I don't remember the whole
poem, but I remember that much.
And we had a lot
of active things.
My father exposed us
to a lot of things.
We traveled a lot
at an early age.
Every year-- every year
we went to Italy to--
to-- for summertime.
And so I loved the train.
I loved to train.
I loved it.
I loved that rhythm of the way
the tracks are put together.
And they don't fit perfectly,
and it gives a certain noise.
And I love it.
I love it.
And it has a rhythm.
And [PAUSES FOR 3 SECONDS]
so I, I, I--
just traveling on-- just sitting
in a train, I enjoyed it.
Probably being by myself or
not too many people around me
and then seeing the
scenery which changes,
watching the people
and the scenery
and thinking on who
these people could be
and what are they doing.
And it was very
entertaining for me.
And then-- so--
Then sometimes we would go to
Czechoslovakia, which is also
surrounding country of Hungary,
and see things and experience
things.
INT: Was it to visit family,
or just to sight-see?
PF: To see things.
To see things.
We had a very close
family in a sense.
My grandfather had a
huge, enormous huge home
in [INAUDIBLE] in Budapest.
And then every weekend the whole
family would meet there, once
a week almost.
And he had enormous,
big balcony he had.
And then the whole
family would sit there,
and we would have
breakfast there,
and we would talk
with each other.
And it was really
beautiful, you know.
That-- it was peaceful
and beautiful.
And--
INT: Which school did
you go to in, in--
PF: In Hungary, I went
to an elementary school.
It's a different system
like, like in America.
In Hungary, you go four years
to an elementary school.
And after, you
switch to a school
what here you would call maybe
a high school kind of thing.
But it's different because
over there, eight years-- now,
after the four years
you are finished,
you go eight years
into the same school.
And then you graduate there,
and then you go to college
if you want to and so on.
So I went to the [INAUDIBLE]
Jewish School in Hungary.
INT: So how-- were your comrades
in school and you had friends?
PF: Did I have friends in
school? [BACKGROUND NOISE]
INT: Yeah.
PF: I had some friends,
yes. [PAUSES FOR 3 SECONDS]
And some of them died.
And that was very sad,
after the war when
I discovered that they died.
But when I went to
school, I had a family--
we knew-- my father knew-- my
father knew that family called
the [? Landesmant ?] family.
And they had about
four or five members
of that family going
to that school.
And they were very
close friends of mine.
Because of family ties
through my parents,
they were friends, so we
were very close friends.
But basically I was
a very open kid,
and I was friendly
to almost everybody.
Almost everybody.
Sometimes cruel, very
cruel, but friendly.
Sometimes I made very cruel
practical jokes in school.
There was, in my days-- I don't
know, do you want to hear it?
INT: Yes, please.
PF: In my days, we had for
the ink what we were writing,
we had a little ink holder.
It looked like a top
hat turned around.
And that's where the ink was in.
And then we had a pen.
You had to immerse the pen
and then write with it.
And there was also plenty
of empty, these ink
holders, no ink in them.
And, and one of my friends
next to me, sitting next to me,
was clowning and picking
up these empty ink holders
and putting them on his head,
like he would be saluting
to people with these top hats.
And I switched one of
these empties with one
which was full with ink.
And then he picked it up
and put it on his head.
And he didn't realize
what's happening.
And he was just keep on going.
And the teacher didn't
see what's happening.
And then slowly the ink started
pouring out on his face.
He still didn't realize it.
And then the whole class
started laughing enormously.
And then naturally the teacher
stopped it and realized it.
And then he had to go
out and wash himself.
And he was a close and
very good-hearted friend.
But he was like the
son of Frankenstein,
a huge person, about four
times bigger than I was.
And after the class was
over, [PAUSES FOR 3 SECONDS]
he chased me.
And he caught up with
me, and he picked me up,
and he pushed me
against the wall.
And then he let me go,
and then I just fell down.
He really didn't hurt me, and--
[PAUSES FOR 3 SECONDS] but just
was very angry for
a very good reason.
So I went home and
everything and I was in bed
when-- and it was late, and
my mother said-- I was almost
getting ready to sleep.
And my mother said,
somebody's calling you.
And his name was Steiner.
And Steiner-- Robert
Steiner was his name.
And he was calling me and
[PAUSES FOR 3 SECONDS]
he cried on the telephone.
And he said, I hope I
didn't hurt you when
I threw you against the wall.
And this is something
so beautiful
that I won't forget
as long as I live.
And more so because after the
war was over I met his mother.
And I said to her mother--
they lived very close
where we lived-- I asked
her mother, I said,
where is Robbie?
And she said, well,
didn't you know?
I said, no.
Know what?
And Robbie survived.
And after the war, after
the war for us in Budapest,
the war wasn't over, his mother
sent him out to get bread.
And he went out to get
bread, and a small bomb
hit him and tore him
into pieces, and he died.
And that's how I found
out that he died.
INT: Do you know which year?
PF: That was in
1945, early 1945.
Because we were liberated
in January 1945,
and so that was after
the liberation or so.
And so I never going to
forget Robbie, my friend.
And I hope he's listening to
me. [PAUSES FOR 3 SECONDS] And
[PAUSES FOR 5 SECONDS] many,
many people in the school I,
[PAUSES FOR 4 SECONDS]
I didn't know.
But it was an
interesting thing also,
an experience that-- because
there was not enough room.
We had to switch.
So there were girls separately
and boys going separately
in the same classes.
But let's say the boys would be
going from 8:00 in the morning
till noon, and the girls would
come at 12:30 and be till 4:00.
And one day-- one day, I left
my book in-- in-- in my place
where I was sitting.
And my name was written
in it, Peter Fischl.
And so the a girl who sat in the
same place knew who sits there.
And she carved in,
heaven knows why,
she carved in this wooden
[PAUSES FOR 3 SECONDS] chair
in the writing arrangement--
I don't know if you're
familiar with it, old European
school system where you sit
and then here is
where you write.
And everything is
made out of wood.
And she carved in that--
she carved in a heart
and she said-- she wrote in--
carved in, 'I love you, Peter.'
And, and till this day,
I'm thinking who Renee
could have been.
And many times,
I'm thinking was--
that I should have maybe made
a harder effort to search
for her, which I did not.
It's kind of the
mystery woman in my life
and the mystery
person in my life.
INT: How old were
you at that time?
PF: Oh, probably 12 or 13.
And then [PAUSES FOR 5 SECONDS]
because maybe I'm
thinking of her a lot, maybe
because she was only person who
just sent love towards me.
And so that was something,
an interesting thing.
INT: What do you mean by the
only one sending you love?
PF: Well, because in
life-- because in life,
you meet people and
then you fall in love
and then later on
disappointments start coming
and-- because nobody's
perfect and so on.
So then relationships
weaken, marriages
are breaking up, like mine.
And with her, there
was nothing like that
because that's the only
experience we had is just
this one writing experience.
INT: So you knew who she was.
PF: I did not know
where she-- who she was.
No, never.
Never.
But it-- maybe it's not too
late to-- to do a search.
And naturally, I still see
her as a certain, you know,
girl in my mind, because
I cannot accept that--
my mind cannot accept
52 years which went by.
And the school was a very
good school, very interesting.
I learned a lot of things.
INT: Peter, can you tell me why
there were not any ink in the,
in the school?
You said there was
some that were empty.
Why, do you know?
PF: I think that was
just a matter of chance,
and heaven knows why those
little ink holders were empty
and they were there.
I have no idea.
Maybe-- it could been that
maybe not in every space people
were sitting.
And only maybe they filled
up the places with ink
where somebody was
sitting and writing.
So maybe it was
every three or four
places where nobody
was sitting, there
is no ink on those things.
And maybe somebody
pulled them out.
INT: OK.
There was no--
PF: Maybe Robbie
pulled it out himself.
I don't remember that detail.
But I just remember the fact
that he had these empties
around him and he was clowning.
That's when my mind
started working and doing
this thing towards him.
INT: What were you
doing with your sister?
How old was your sister at--
PF: My sister is about 2 and
1/2 years older than I am.
So basically I lived a very
lonely life as a child,
because my sister was a
very attractive young lady.
And so at age 12,
13, there was a lot
of boys who were interested in
her and came up to our house
and sat around there.
And sometimes there
was 10, 15 boys
sitting there just to be around
my sister and talk with her.
And nobody was really
interested in me.
And my father was a
very busy businessman
and under tremendous pressure.
I really don't recall
a lot of things,
a lot of times where he
really would have been
with me and with us really.
I, I, I just remember sometimes
dinners and breakfasts
and, and lunches.
But I really don't remember
that my father and I would have,
what they say here in America,
would have went fishing.
I never went fishing
with my father.
I could write a book about this.
INT: What was your
father doing exactly?
PF: Well, my grandmother
and my grandfather
came from a small town where
they worked themself up
into business.
And so my-- when my father was
a little boy, they-- his parents
were very well doing already.
And so my grandmother made
it sure that my father
goes into a good school
and meets the right people.
And then he set my
father up in business.
Actually, my grandfather
had a business
called Leopold Fischl and Son.
And their business is something
which, to my knowledge,
is-- it's probably around
in America, too, or was,
but I never heard of it.
Is a person who works with
the large farmers and--
Let's say, here the
government helps
the farmers, the medium
farmers and large farmers.
In, in, in Hungary,
my father would
be like working with these
medium and large farming
people, and let's say
buying the livestock a year
or two years ahead of the
time before they really
want to sell it.
So actually they worked
with my father's money.
And then once the
livestock grew up,
then, then it
belonged to my father.
And they made their profit, and
then my father would resell it,
export it also.
My father exported
to Israel also.
And matter of fact,
matter of fact, my father
gave some livestock as gifts to
Israel to a kibbutz in Israel.
And I don't remember
now the name,
but I think it was a kibbutz
where Hannah Senesh wanted
to go, I think.
You heard of Hannah Senesh.
INT: At what time--
what time period?
PF: Well, that was before
she escaped from Hungary
and got captured.
That was done in probably
in 1938, 1938 or so.
At that time in Israel, they
had problems with the British.
And so this was part of
my father's business.
But my father was
[PAUSES FOR 4 SECONDS] doing
anything besides this, which--
he was what you would call,
like, an entrepreneur.
[PAUSES FOR 3 SECONDS] He made
a lot of money, but if somebody
would come in and would offer
him a apartment building, a
hundred-unit apartment building
for a good price,
then he would buy it.
INT: Great.
PF: And, ant that's how
I could describe him.
He was a very creative person.
And-- [PAUSES FOR 5 SECONDS]
But he also took
a lot of chances
in, in-- he never
lost his money,
but he took a lot of chances
in his business dealings.
So he was under
tremendous pressure,
[PAUSES FOR 4 SECONDS]
in-- I could see.
INT: Thank you.